there's no shortage of support for the
strikers here
and this resistance is about to swell in
size Hollywood's writers who have been
treading these Pavements for two months
now are being joined by the actors who
bring their words to life what
I feel like we're a resilient bunch and
La is a union town and
we're gonna go as far as we need I feel
like it's War honestly I feel like it's
warm is war
a dual strike hasn't happened since 1960
it will bring the TV and film industry
to a grinding halt how long are you
willing to be at work work for as long
as it takes you chose the wrong group to
mess with in terms of not being employed
because we uh we're good at this
negotiations with production companies
down over royalty payments which actors
say are pitiful they also fear the rise
of artificial intelligence taking away
jobs the union president announced the
strike we are the victims here
we are being
victimized by a very greedy entity
I am shocked by the way the people that
we have been in business with are
treating us I cannot believe it
at the Oppenheimer Premiere in London
actors like Killian Murphy and Emily
Blunt walked out as news of the strike
was confirmed
streaming giants like Netflix and Amazon
say that they put a fair deal on the
table and the actor's demands were
unrealistic
the two sides seemed further away than
ever Hollywood is still recovering from
the pandemic and an economic crisis it
will now be a case of whose blinks first
Martha kalner Sky News Hollywood